40 kilometers off the coast of brazil
lies an island so
dangerous it's illegal to visit
but rules don't apply to you you're a
thrill-seeking adrenaline junkie ready
to camp out for 30 days in the untamed
wilderness of snake island
where would you find shelter
how long would you live if you got bit
and what would happen if you bit the
snake
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you spent a month on snake
island
without resources or help the average
person wouldn't last long on this
tropical death trap
back in 2019 when a fishing boat sank
near the island two people remained on
the ship
yeah that's right they decided to take
their chances in a sinking boat
rather than spend one second on this
serpent-infested island
and the few that do risk their lives
going into the rainforest
may have questionable motives
but
why would anybody risk their lives to
visit this island
most people who come to ilha the
cuamadegrande or snake island
don't want to stay for more than a few
hours
if you're here for a month
stay near the shoreline
going past the tree line deep into the
forest could be fatal
experts estimate there's at least one
snake per square meter across the
430 000 square meter island
so
what kind of reptilian killers would you
be on the lookout for
well how about as many as 4 000 golden
lancehead vipers
and they're all waiting on slow moving
targets like you
to give them something to sink their
fangs into
separated from the mainland 11 000 years
ago
the snakes here evolved venom powerful
enough to kill their prey quickly to
catch the migratory birds passing
through
this venom five times more potent than
that of the closest mainland snakes
would kill you within an hour if left
untreated
it's even strong enough to melt your
skin
while these island dwellers prefer an
avian diet
catching you would provide a lovely
feast
the venom in your system could damage
your kidneys destroy your muscle tissue
or cause internal bleeding
all of which could kill you
and these dangerous vipers stand between
you and fresh water sources further
inland
instead of risking your life for a drink
you could use leaves to collect rain
water
as hunger sets in you could eat bananas
found at the edge of the forest near the
coastline
and if desperation sets in
you could try eating one of these snakes
before they eat you
okay let's clear something up poisonous
is not the same as venomous
poisons cause harm when swallowed or
inhaled
the toxins in snake venom aren't harmful
as long as they're not in your
bloodstream
so if you caught a viper and uh
removed its head where the poison glands
sit
you could snack on it
oh that does taste like chicken
unfortunately you wouldn't be the only
one looking to catch this viper
bio pirates and poachers often come to
snake island and no not for the beaches
just one golden lancehead viper could
bring in 30 000 on the black market
that might be the most expensive meal
you've ever eaten
since
1981 even drug companies have been using
their venom in medications to treat high
blood pressure
it's believed that due to this high
demand the viper population here has
decreased a staggering 50 percent in
just 15 years
placing it on the endangered species
list
but get in the way of these profiteers
or venomous snakes and you would be the
real endangered species on this island
you know if you held on to those poison
glands well maybe you could have a
refreshing drink for later
come to think of it what would happen if
you swallowed snake venom
well grab your cocktail shaker and slice
up some limes because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]